The next optimization view mode I'd like to talk about
is Nanite.
Now, Nanite has a number of different optimization view
modes we can see to inspect everything that's going on.
And the reason that I want to bring this up
is while all of these view modes that Nanite offers
are useful, it is the view mode
that is happening on this slide that
is of most importance to us.
The Nanite overdraw view mode.
The overdraw view mode here will show us
areas which Nanite meshes have been
stacked over the top of one another
and could present performance issues.
While Nanite is very, very, very powerful,
there are certain things that we need to be aware of in
order to make sure that we wield this power responsibly.
And one of those is that stacking multiple Nanite meshes
on the top of one another can make Nanite
perform less than optimal.
And the Nanite overdraw mode will show us this.
And this mode, as with our other ones,
we're looking for areas of very bright orange.
That's going to show us areas
where it could be very expensive to render
the Nanite in that particular area.
Again, like with all of our optimization view modes,
what we're trying to do is make sure
that we have a general ideal situation going on
across our entire map, and that the areas that
are very expensive or expensive are worth that cost.
If it's happening in an area that's, say,
out of the main area of interaction,
then we're going to want to optimize that area.
However, if we do have some expensive and very expensive
areas, but they're within the area the user is going
to interact with, they might be worth that expense
depending on the setup you have in fall.
Again, remember, the idea here is to mitigate
and not completely eliminate and make sure
that you keep an eye on areas that could possibly
have performance issues or areas that are suffering
from performance issues.
And this gives you a good idea of why they are.